we report these stories far too often
pedestrians being killed on our streets
that's right well across the country
pedestrian deaths have risen 80 percent
since 2009 and today many cars come with
technology to help prevent pedestrian
accidents but as john langler reports a
new study finds it falls short at night
so far this year at least 76 people have
already died on clark county roads and
many victims pedestrians hit and killed
by cars the valley has a sad long
history of these tragedies car
technology still has a long way to go to
try and keep everyone safe this is
surveillance video from march it shows
two sisters walking on a florida
sidewalk at night seconds later a car
hits and kills one of them
many newer vehicles have automatic
emergency braking studies by the
insurance institute for highway safety
show these symptoms typically perform
well in daylight however that's not the
case when it gets dark of the 23
vehicles tested at night only four
received a superior rating
the ford mustang maquis the nissan
pathfinder and then the toyota
highlander and the toyota camry those
were the four vehicles that got our best
rating
iihs president david harkey says 15
other vehicles received an advanced or
basic rating and four cars didn't
qualify at all
nationwide more than 7 300 pedestrians
were killed last year three quarters at
night harkey hopes automakers can
quickly make improvements to this
pedestrian safety technology they
believe that they can do this with the
existing technology with some small
tweaks john langler 8 news now